I have Megan Santa key I'm an
open-source strategist for Google cloud
and I am really excited to be here to
lead this panel where you can meet the
authors of go and well why don't I first
just let them introduce themselves to
you
hi yeah my name is Ian Taylor I've been
working on go since 2008 before it
became public I'm a Google employee and
I work on the tools and the libraries
and many other things my name is Robert
Van Kent I am not actually one of the
inventors of go but I started
programming ago about five years ago
working on machine management tools
inside Google I converted a bunch of
machine management applications from
Python to go and I joined the go team
last year and since then I've been
working on the go cloud development kit
a set of tools for making cloud
application and go awesome hi I'm Robert
Griesemer I've been with the go team
since 2007 when it was started which is
like 12 years ago which seems like a
crazy long time I've written a bunch of
tools that some of people a few guys
might be using like Gotham so if you're
not happy with that you can complain
with me I may not help though and more
recently I've been working on trying to
get go into that go to phase I am a Brad
Fitzpatrick I've been working on gos
since 2010 and I work on the standard
library a lot things like the HTTP
packages and the build system I wrote
like go imports it's just kind of I
bounced around to lots of little places
hi my name is Tyler Bui Paul Sulak I
work on go on Google cloud so my goal is
to make it as easy as possible to use go
with and on GCP so I just kind of like
Robert said if you have problems with go
on GCP you can maybe be annoyed at me it
might help
excellent okay so these are wonderful go
experts will be the panelists and I just
want to get a sense for the room before
we get going can you raise your hand if
you have never used go before all right
well welcome we're excited to start
teaching you more about go can you raise
your hand if you've started using it a
little bit all right and then raise your
hand if you're using it a lot all right
excellent
we love that good so we'll have a little
bit of answers for each stage that
you're in and as I was mentioned before
this is going to be interactive we have
some questions that I'm going to ask
that have come in but we are going to
take questions from the audience so if
you do have a question you can just
start making your way down to the sides
both of these team members are going to
have microphones where you could ask
your questions you can just queue up
okay so why don't we just get started
with a nice easy one so tell me what is
go best at doing like what are all great
ways that you should be using go so it's
good for everything of course of course
it's very good for a cloud it's a simple
language it's easy to write code it's
easy to write code that runs very
efficiently it's easy to write code that
runs very concurrently a lot of the core
infrastructure of the cloud is written
in go itself like kubernetes is an easy
example and I mean yeah it's it's well
designed for web servers good for a lot
of things I was just gonna say I like I
said I started using go when I converted
a bunch of large Python applications
where they were pretty performant
sensitive and the scale of Google's
machines was just getting so large that
Python wasn't working anymore and go was
what's really gate great for concurrency
and also for just managing a large
application having a type safe language
it's a lot easier to manage
and then title something that we hear a
lot from people is how easy it is to
learn though so it's probably not an
exaggeration that if you know how to
program within a week you can be
productive in though I mean it's been a
number of years since I was like super
religious about go but at the time I was
always telling people how I hated the
trade-offs of all the other programming
languages were like if you wanted to
write performance you know sensitive
code you would have to write kind of a
tedious language and if you want to
write like in a fun language then you
would have to deal with bad concurrency
or lots of you know callbacks or bad
performance or like you know runtime
failures due to like you know missing
type information and so it was really
nice to write in a language that was
both fun and fast and then like let you
get going and write code right away so
I'm still kind of in love with it I
haven't found anything that's as fun and
like just productive I think one other
thing I'll call out is part of one of
our one of the goals of designing go was
to make it easy to develop in large
teams over large amounts of time or long
amounts of time so stuff like go pump
and go imports and kind of standardizing
the language and how it's used makes it
so that when you're looking at go code
in one spot made by one person it looks
very similar and hopefully easy to
understand as go code you've seen
somewhere else good so do we have any
other questions from the audience just
to remind you to come down yeah go on
over hi my name is Pablo I have a
question for you what do you think about
a basal bill system for go
what do I think about the basil built
system for go I think I think it's very
good for complicated programs I mean go
go comes with its own build system in
the sense that it's easy to build pure
go programs with the tools that are
provided by go but if you want to work
on a multi language program with many
different parts also if you want to deal
with a lot of generated code then I
think basil works really effectively it
does have full support for go these days
and I mean lots of people use it we use
it internally we use Google's internal
version of it so yeah it's a good system
wait you say it has full support but
there's a lot of things in like X tools
like the package loader and stuff that's
kind of like in development so like a
lot of a lot of the tools that that
exist in the go ecosystem kind of
historically assumed that you laid out
your code on disk the way that goes
built-in build system works and so
there's an increasing amount of work
recently about making our tools agnostic
about whether you're using basil or
you're using the go tool so it's getting
better like only in the last maybe year
okay that's a good point especially for
generated code okay great and I think we
have another question coming in so I
didn't do what Tyler was talking about
the benefits of go or what is what it is
good for I feel it's very good for
collaborative development where you can
it's so easy to import somebody else's
github repo and their libraries and
Cobra is something that almost everybody
who develop some CLI or the other might
have used so
that's that's one thing that I wanted to
kind of point out the other my specific
question that I had was is there plans
of importing like commonly used github
repos into the standard library on the
contrary we want to get rid of things in
the standard library we even have a FAQ
entry about it
I mean right now stuff exists in the
standard library just because initially
there was no like gogit and so if we
wanted to put some code somewhere it had
to be in the standard library I mean
there used to be like a space Wars game
there was a nntp like using that client
there was I mean there was like tons of
crap in the standard library and right
before go on we deleted a ton of it and
we forgot to delete like even more of it
so there's a lot of things that are in
there they're kind of an accident
and like we didn't have internal
packages or like you know like private
packages so there's a lot of crap that's
in there just for like TLS that's only
public because of HTTP and so there's a
whole lot of like low-level crypto
networking details that are like we
wouldn't really want to expose on their
own we might want them to live on github
or something anyway so I don't I don't
think the trend is to like put more
stuff in the standard library it's
really to make it smaller and more
modular but I want to add to that with
the go modules work that's going on
actively and go right now we're making
it much easier for a program to pull in
a reliably determined set of sources
from an external library and we're also
developing better module discovery and
package discovery tools so that people
will be able to find the packages that
they want and also have a way of knowing
that these are packages that a lot of
other people use and are therefore
highly reliable and it's tempting to
move everything into the standard
library but it doesn't solve the problem
of who's going to actually maintain it
the go team is not particularly large
and so we don't want to put something in
the standard library which we can't take
care of ourselves but what we do instead
want to make it possible is that you can
build your go program and know that
you're pulling in libraries written and
maintained by other people that you know
are high quality because other people
vouch for them
that's the direction we want to move in
that's great okay we have another
question over here my question for Tyler
seems that God have been lunch and near
me about ten years ago as well as Google
cloud me about 10 years ago and but from
my point of view support off go in
Google cloud and google appengine
flexible environment still looks that as
a phishing from my point of view are you
guys prefer Java aren't you yeah I think
this is something that we've really
tried to improve in the last couple
years so a couple things that are new
our App Engine standard second gen
runtimes so these like this idea applies
for all of the App Engine supported
languages but specifically for go if you
ever use the App Engine standard before
and you had to import App Engine like
anyone raise your hand used okay a
couple people so now you can use
whatever library you want kind of before
one of the issues that would come up is
you had to use a special package to make
HTTP requests so you run your service on
App Engine you need to make some API
call you can't use net HTTP you need to
use URL fetch which was this other
package that we maintained now latest
version of go that's not something you
need to do anymore much much nicer to
use and that's all based on G by Z that
same technology was used for cloud
functions and so we released cloud
functions support for go about a year
ago I want to say starting with an alpha
and beta and go 111 for cloud functions
just went to G a so those are some of
the ways that we've tried to improve
support and then the one other way to
run your go code is cloud run and that's
you can run whatever language you want
whatever language version you want and
as long as you're using the cloud client
libraries hopefully that's a nice
experience
and then you mentioned app engine flex
that's kind of for someone who hasn't
used it it's similar to App Engine
standard you can also provide your own
container images that you want to run it
will scale up for you but it has a
minimum instance count of one so you're
kind of that's the default level and
then if you're comparing that to cloud
run which so how many people saw that
announcement it was in the keynote today
ok a lot more people
so cloud run is like surveillance
containers so you define whatever
container am in g1 and that can bundle
whatever go version you want and then
that scales up and down really quickly
if you deploy it literally takes a few
seconds it's really really nice so where
we're working on it
I hope it's much better than it was say
three five years ago and I wanted to put
it in a plug for my project the go cloud
development kit we're an open another
open source project and we're trying to
make go a great language for developing
cloud applications not just died not
just on TCP but on any cloud including
on pram or running on your local box so
we've developed a bunch of portable
api's for cloud services like blob or
pub/sub things like that and then we
have implementations for different cloud
providers so you write your app once
using our api's native go api's and then
you kind of plug in with simple config
or initialization time changes you plug
in whatever implementation you want if
you want to run locally on your box you
use that implementation if you want to
run on Amazon you plug in s3 or SNS for
pub/sub and so that way you sort of have
flexibility and good development
workflow
okay anything else bad Oh
if now we do have a question coming in I
just have a question with regards to
webassembly what is the road map for you
know integrating go with what assembly
is will there be one day where we can do
away with JavaScript and have go replace
it I hope so
by now I mean it's getting better none
of us are really doing the web assembly
back-end there's some people in the NGO
team that are reviewing it but it's
mostly done from external contributions
there was just a change that landed that
made it smaller and faster the output
the status today is you could take
programs and compile them for a web
assembly and you could run it on you
know alongside node.js stuff where you
can run it in the browser and there's
kind of a ecosystem of kind of UI
framework stuff so you can write it
front-end web apps and you can you can
write it all today without any
JavaScript at all so um you know it's
nice --nt but it's coming along and
actually I just want to see if we're
hearing a little bit through these
questions what's new with modules and
other aspects functions you know could
you just tell us a can one big arcing
story what is new with go there's a lot
happening
well I can talk a little bit about the
changes to the language so until the
most recent release to 112 we have made
almost no changes to the language after
an initial phase where we made small
minor changes so for the last couple of
years we basically have frozen the
language even when it comes to smart
small minor adjustments that would have
been fully backward-compatible but now
we're trying to move forward towards
what we call sort of go to and as part
of this process we've started to look at
the incoming proposals that they come
from the open-source community and we
review them and we identify the ones
that seem promising and so for 113 for
instance we have started making the
first significant changes to the
language so now you will have with 113
assuming we're going to actually say yes
at the very end of the development cycle
we'll have binary literals there's gonna
be extra that small floating-point
numbers another thing is we can do now
shifts without non constant shifts
without you int conversion which is
probably going to clean up a lot of code
and that's what comes tomorrow and
literals can have underbar so if you
have very long numbers you can have now
underscores in there to space them out
apparently something that people really
want it and there is probably gonna be
some changes to the libraries which I
probably not have the best overview at
the moment I was also going to add that
all these language changes that are
coming are kind of like warm-up ones for
us to work on the process so they're
kind of boring and they're kind of small
but it's we're gonna do a couple
additions to the language we're gonna do
a couple removals to the language and
kinda like get practice with that
process there's a couple constructs in
the language that we would like to maybe
remove and so modules lets you specify
wanna give on the granularity of a
module what language version semantics
you want so if you say like you're
targeting go 112 we can remove something
and go what 13 as long as your module
still declares 112 that language feature
exists but once you want some like new
feet
shirring go 114 and you say that then
you lose the features that we removed
and go 113 so well it lets us like
slowly evolve the language without
breaking anyone so there may not
actually be a go to ever we say go to as
in like new stuff but it may just be
that like you know generics or something
fun lands and like go 117 and so keep
that in mind whenever we said go to it's
probably more of a marketing expression
than actually a thing and just to call
out the three main things being looked
at by the team for go to our dependency
management and so modules are the go
solution to that came out starting in
111 now again in 112 and then hopefully
on by default and 113 and then the
others are errors and generics so errors
the goal there is to make it easier to
develop and respond to and check errors
and then last one generics of basically
deciding should we include them should
we not if we do in what form thank you I
think we have a question Brian actually
just answered my original question so a
different question I think one of gos
strengths as you mentioned is how few
features it has and when could you give
an example of a feature in another
language that you really like that
wouldn't make sense and go
it was a good one you get a plushy
well C++ for example is a very complex
language but it has a number of features
that are very nice for example in C++
you can template eyes based on a
constant and use that to compile
different versions of your code based on
constants that are passed into the
template and you can combine that with
very attic templates so you can actually
redesign your data structures based on
how the template is expanded to make
them more or less efficient depending on
the exact features you need from the
data structure you can actually change
how much memory it requires at compile
time so that's a cool feature and I've
used that feature myself when I've
written in C++ in the past but the
complexity of understanding how that
feature really works I don't think it's
appropriate for a language let go which
is designed to be you know as Robert
said earlier it's a language you can
learn very quickly if you're familiar
with other programming languages even if
you're not familiar with other languages
it's a great language to start with we
don't want features like that I think
and go but it's a great question though
I mean in general go tries to give you
like 80% of what you want to look like
20% of the complexity because you know
every time you try to solve a little bit
more get it closer to 100% of what you
want the complexities ramps up like way
faster than the what you're delivering
there's one feature that's relatively
easy to understand a thing which is
macros which Co doesn't have but and you
know there's plenty of times when I
really really really wanted to have just
write a macro but the problem with a
macro is it's it's possible to write
code that's almost undecipherable
afterwards so it's easy you know it's
it's like right once understand never so
it's it's so it's a feature that
definitely is not part of the language
that we don't want to have in the
language because we put a lot of
emphasis on readability of go because
code in our experience is read much more
often than with
and so that's a that's a valuable
feature to maintain great I think we
have another question coming in yeah so
go is about ten years old now so if you
can comment a little bit about what the
motivations that drove you to develop go
ten years ago and are these drivers
still valid today so this is a question
that's been answered many times on the
web but let me sort of try to shortcut
it so in 2007 there was a lot of code to
be written at Google still there's a lot
of code to be written at Google and some
of us really felt like at that time the
choice of programming languages was
somewhat unsatisfactory so we were
somewhat stuck between a rock and a hard
place if you will some people call it
Java and C++ but so we there was a
strong desire to have something better
and so we we embarked on coming up with
something that felt like a much better
solution at that time to the kind of
systems programming that we wanted to do
because it seemed that a lot of the
problems were actually solved many many
years maybe decades before but were not
actually solved in programming languages
that were available at that time and so
I think a lot of those things are still
maybe a little bit less true today
because there's actually a wider variety
of languages but when it comes to things
like concurrency I think go is still
like way in the forefront it's I don't
know of any other language where it's so
easy to write concurrent code in terms
of compactness I think go is still
extremely small language and very easy
to you know grasp and understand so I
think many of these things are still
valid and of course that language is
not just compact and small and clean but
it's also very efficient and I think
that's still true I mean we're still
we're maybe not at C or C++ level but we
are close enough for you know 99% of all
applications and I want to also allude
to something that Tyler mentioned
earlier which is that go the language
was designed for as much as possible for
programming in the large for many people
working together on one program and a
lot of decisions about the language were
made with that in mind you know how well
we succeeded at it I'm not sure but I
think it was an important goal at the
time and I think it's even more
important now especially is open-source
has continued to get larger and larger
and larger languages that help people
work in larger groups I think is very
important very important goal for modern
languages and I think au has aimed for
that all along okay I know we have a
very patient person over here who's
waiting to ask a question
one of the things I've really enjoyed
about Doh is the community and I'm
wondering how you all stay engaged with
the community and help build baths
especially in the face of contentious
decisions or changes to the language so
the question is about the community and
how we well how we work with it I guess
yeah the community for NGO has been has
been incredible we've had so much
support from you know from all of you
from people all around the world working
and going contributing to go and then
you asked how do we deal with
contentious decisions I think we try to
I think we try to be as open as possible
about how we're making our decisions and
I shouldn't even say as open as possible
we try to be completely open about why
we're deciding the way we're deciding
and they do things Nuka contentious at
times there are disagreements in the
community of course there have been
disagreements in the past and we listen
to them I mean an easy example is for
the product you know the language added
a feature type aliases maybe three four
years ago and before type aliases were
introduced we actually had a separate
proposal which was a different kind of
aliasing proposal and we designed it
Robert and I both worked on it and other
people within Google we put it out there
saying this is something we think will
be useful that we'd like to add language
and there was a lot of pushback in the
community it did become contentious and
I think we tried as hard as we can't
could to listen to it we withdrew the
proposal we put out a smaller and
simpler proposal which did get then get
added to the language also we explained
you know the use cases for it and so I
think it's been a learning process for
all of us to work with the community but
I feel like you know the answer really
is just to be just to be open to explain
why we're thinking what we're thinking
we can't take every idea that comes in
we don't agree with every idea that
comes in ultimately you know a small
group of people is going to make the
very final decisions about what's going
to happen but still most of the best
ideas have come in from outside
so yeah that's great
you know things important any other
comments on that one okay then I'm gonna
take a question on this side all right
so you guys are great at keeping stuff
backwards-compatible but if you go if
you could go tomorrow to work and just
change something completely without
thinking about it what would that be so
um if you can go back all the way to the
beginning of go
the original go look very very different
than the one that we have now and in the
early days we had the luxury to actually
make a lot of changes for instance the
very first version of God you had to
write semicolons and now you don't have
to write them anymore actually you know
for last ten years didn't have to write
them and there's a whole bunch of things
that we probably would like to remove
some of which we can't remove right now
one of them again a simple example is
right now you can convert it you can say
string off an integer and that gives you
the corresponding it doesn't give you a
string version of that integer value it
gives you the corresponding Unicode code
point as a string so to speak and that's
very confusing and that's that was there
just for historic reasons because it was
convenient in the beginning and that's
something we want to write I want to
take out but we can't because it's very
potentially things and there's a there's
a lot of other things probably I don't
have a good list in my head at the
moment but ranging over a string giving
you the UT utf-8 code points rather than
the bytes of the string which is
inconsistent with a slicer by its
there's things like when you do a
arrange loop and you want to capture you
have a closure that captures one of the
variables the variables are is like the
same variable for the whole loop brother
than every iteration of the loop so you
can't safely start a go routine with a
closure in the middle of a loop and that
bites a lot of people so there's a lot
of little things that you know we
realized after the fact but we can't
really change it Eric get rid of return
statements that don't list the values
that are being returned
from the beginning we tried to make go
really platform-independent
and so most of the language is actually
platformer any better you can write some
code and you can run it on any platform
but some basic things like the integer
type int or you int
they are platform dependent you know if
you're running on a 32-bit platform II
you get a 32-bit in and if you're
running on a 64-bit platform you're
running you're getting potentially a
64-bit in maybe maybe a 32-bit in so
that's actually something that I think
in retrospect was probably a mistake
because if you actually move from one
platform to another you might incur
problems so you may have to change code
and things like that so we nice if we'd
had a better solution for that and one
approach could be or could have been
maybe that an int is arbitrary size you
know and the compiler does the right
thing and you never have to worry about
it that's something that would be much
much harder or it's going to be much
much harder to do now we have a few
minutes left so we've got a few
questions people are queuing up so we'll
see if we can go quickly answer some
more chairs really quickly uh what would
you say has been the biggest challenge
in creating go or just a programming
language in general I mean is it the
intricate technicalities or is it
understanding user behavior and creating
something to adapt to user behavior
so what's been the biggest challenge and
go I'd say that for me at least the
biggest challenge is keeping it simple
it's always so easy to add another
feature and you can see so clearly how
useful it would be to have this new
facility in the language but if we add
every new facility in the language then
we got something so complicated that is
very difficult to use like some existing
languages today and so I'd say the
biggest challenge has been to say no
okay okay over here it's mandatory to
pass the context No what do you think
about it and also I've read in the
internet somewhere that contact will be
removed in go I don't know there are no
plans to remove context if anything will
become more pervasive in my natural
regime of passing the context in the
first argument do you think everybody
should do it outside Google yeah
probably so inside Google a lot of it
was kind of implicit with like magic
thread local stuff and so it was kind of
great when it worked because your
context was threaded through
automatically because all all functions
just kind of picked it up from a thread
local storage but once you start to do
something tricky a lot of people didn't
know how to stitch together their
threads their context and they wouldn't
even know that they didn't do it until
they had a production problem and they
went to look at like the the the global
trace dashboard and then they noticed
that none of their stuff was stitched
together properly so if you make it
explicit you get it right from the
beginning so when you have a production
problem it's you know it's usable the
the traces
and as far as whether the context is the
first argument or not it's convenient to
have it to be the first argument it just
makes it the code be stylistically
consistent but it doesn't have any
meaning beyond that it just helps if the
code looks similar in different parts of
Google one thing I'd like to do is maybe
make context context be less stuttery
because right now you write you know C T
X and so if you're reading it it's like
context context context and if right now
we have one built-in type in the
language that one built-in interface
type which is error which is just an
alias you know for anything with an
error string method so it'd be kind of
nice maybe just make context first class
too and make that built-in so at least
then it would be used to be context
context or something
okay so why don't we just get add we can
get one maybe two questions and we'll
start on this side I for such a new
language I think my math is right but
there's like over 50 years of experience
and knowledge just on this stage
can we get maybe one tip from each of
you on like for writing and go and
getting into the go mindset
I'll start and I'll take an easy one run
go funk and require it on submit
you should run it on save as you're
writing your code same ways go imports
small functions lost lots of tests flava
Teton the in the playground and you know
experiment be careful with contacts I've
had a lot of bugs with using the wrong
context in the wrong place
be explicit about what you're trying to
do keep your functions
you know don't use implicit information
pass between functions
okay great we're gonna sneak in one last
question and then we'll wrap it up hi
everyone I have a question for Brad you
started writing the second iteration of
the net HDTV package can you talk a
little bit about the problems you have
with the your original iteration of it
and maybe what the status is well I have
a long wiki page about all the things I
kind of dislike about the first one
which kind of grew organically over ten
years or so so I don't really have time
in 30 seconds to go over that but the
current status is I got distracted and
you know there were other fires and
stuff so I it's still my goal it's like
probably the highest priority thing I
should be doing is finishing up the the
new HTTP client we're all looking
forward to it
okay well we're out of time but thank
you so much for joining us and all your
great questions all the credit goes to
these great experts in the community and
it's building go
[Music]